my talk is titled the valley of no
results business lessons may be life
lessons if I get preachy enough from
analyzing pizza-delivery data and so no
my talk is not over I just wanted to
thank you all for coming here you might
leave after a few slides so I wanted to
thank you for at least showing up for
the beginning and that's me and that
iron man Seuk metaphorically giving all
you love so here's this table of
contents
kind of intro on myself we're gonna look
at the dataset do some statistics and
get insights for male insights and then
do a pitch at the end for all of you to
follow me on Twitter because I have way
less Twitter followers and a lot of
presenters and it's a competition so all
of me is the name of a jazz standard so
it's just I mean you know arbitrary
reference to that jazz standard which is
a song um so so my past I was born in El
Salvador I grew up poor quite poor and I
lived a life between first and second
gen immigrant and because I came here as
a baby and I see the life that a lot of
second-generation immigrants lived and I
don't quite see myself in that but then
I grew up a really sheltered like I
essentially grew up in El Salvador
inside my house sheltered until I went
to school and then started learning
English and so living that kind of made
me real gives me a perspective on
valeting new ones nuance loss in
classification I believe or you know I'm
always now I'm always thinking okay how
does this apply to my career
I tried music for a bit I was a music
major specifically at Jazz Studies
trombone performance major surprisingly
there's not much demand for that major
nobody told me that you know there's not
many jobs for jazz that he's performance
trombone I don't remember and so I
finally ended up in Business Analytics
my final major that I caught a degree in
and I had a fee minus average in
computer science classes and a B average
in math and that was me trying my best
so it was very hard for me to do these
things and you may be wondering about
the picture to type back to growing up
poor my brother and I made our own
pokemon cards you might be thinking oh
is he saying Poisson distribution no
that that's just a misspelled Poisson I
didn't know about that when I was little
so we made our own pokemon cards I saw a
problem and we made our own solution it
might not be a flawless like my now is
my analysis later on might not be
flawless but I tried my best and yeah so
where things are at now so these are two
drugs this is my dog Schubert and that's
my housemates dog Bartok and their
cuties and they have nothing to do with
this slide but they just you know I just
show the picture of them wherever I can
well I guess they I have them now so you
know I guess that's how I realized so
I'm currently a data analyst or database
analyst depending what time in the day
you ask me and the meat and potatoes of
what I do is sequel and I'll script some
things in PowerShell and when I'm really
lucky I get to script some manual
processes in Python
I live in Boise Idaho and which is a bit
different than here and then in the
future I would love to be a data
engineer so if anybody after the talk
has books tutorial or video
recommendations I'd be happy to take
them and that's Bartok and Schubert's
again named after classical composers
right after our bath so they look really
cute and in the future yeah so currently
I'm working like in the - I don't know
if you've all seen this pyramid before
the hierarchy of AI needs are AI hark
hierarchy of needs so I'm currently
working like in the middle two sections
and I'd love to move more towards the
bottom two in the future so I became a
data analyst for practical reasons much
in the same way I made those Pokemon
cards this is because I wanted to play
and in this for data analysis or the
business analytics degree I switch
bluntly because I wanted to make money I
was a jazz from bone major and I wanted
to have autonomy I wanted to be able to
make more money and support the loved
ones in my life being the first one to
graduate college and also the first one
to work a white-collar job work in an
air-conditioned room even was a big deal
and so making that money to be able to
support the loved ones my loved ones was
a big deal and much for the same reason
I started collecting pizza-delivery data
I was delivering pizzas and I wanted to
say more about my experience than I hate
washing the garlic bottles because they
are nasty and so I started collecting a
pizza delivery data so a row for each
delivery i collected around actually
specifically 1,300 oh one or 1300 one
rose and my ex-partner she's a saint she
obliged me and she collected data with
me she would get hand me her slips with
a few fields written in and I would in
put it all into Excel late at night
after we finished delivering pizzas so I
wanted to build technical skills that
meant statistics Python but at first
cement Excel so in Excel I wasn't able
to make bar charts and like line graphs
and but there weren't very many obvious
insights I wanted to do more I wanted to
build the technical skills to be able to
sell to employers and be like okay this
is why I'm worth hiring this is why I'm
worth you know in a business sense being
paid as much money so interviewers first
internship interviews then full-time
interviewers always wanted to know what
are the best predictors for tips
who tips the best what neighborhoods tip
the best what did you learn what two
things can I or what one thing can a
driver do to increase their tips and so
my answer always reminded me of this
quote give me a one-handed economist all
my economists say on the one hand on the
other and so anybody who's done data
analysis knows that data analysis comes
with nuance and a lot of gray areas and
it's not so clear answers a lot of time
and so a lot of these interviewers were
like Harry Truman here it would be like
just give me a straight answer how can
you increase tips and so when I finally
got a data nerd in front of me who was
excited about no work no results like me
that this is me curvy very excited and
this is me right now very excited to
explain the no results ok so a few weeks
ago I went to a conference and I met
some new friends and they told me you
got a do live coding in your
presentation and I was like no i can't
do live coding and so they said you got
a do live coding and so I said ok I want
to do live coding but I'll run code live
like I won't actually type it out
because before I was gonna put like
matplotlib graphs on the screen and I
think running it and like expanding it's
gonna look a lot better so I'll do that
so all that to say I'll prove that I can
be hardcore and do some live coding ok
so let me pull that up I have some
sequel queries if it by the way side
note if anybody knows how to connect to
a CSV file as a database from Python
terminal get at me after because that
would be extremely useful but for now I
am using query storm this really awesome
simple tool in which you can query Excel
worksheets as their own tables in a
database so let's just look at how much
is tipped average for all deliveries
that's 3.39 so not bad
$3 40 cent tip for the average tips out
of three 1300 and if we need know if we
never got a zero tip it'd be three point
six three so those who do tip actually
tip pretty generously three dollars and
sixty cents for average tip is pretty
high that's a good night and let's see
what's this say oh so this is querying
the rows in which someone had a negative
tip so this is two rows I remember the
one that was mine I remember exactly and
the delivery driver we have one angel
one Sam my ex-partner and thirteen cents
I remember I yeah okay that won't get
into that and so if we grab the tip but
gripped by delivery driver we'll see
that I had a lower average tip we'll get
into that later some statistical test I
had a 337 almost 338 and Sam had a 341
average and look at order amounts the
average order amount was twenty one
dollars eighty four cents which makes
sense for this is Domino's so Pizza
tends to be pretty cheap for Domino's
people who are buying teach that they're
looking for a deal not not so much for a
fine night of fine dining and this is a
breakdown of deliveries per neighborhood
so one of the fields I collected was I
generalize okay this this deliveries
from this neighborhood and so I had ten
neighborhoods and I didn't collect any
addresses though I threw those away and
yeah it looks like pretty even
other than the last four pretty even
distribution
and then housing type most deliveries
were to houses apartments all inclusive
in trailers and condos and apart actual
apartment I wish I had collected better
quality on that but you know such as
life and this is the breakdown of
percentage of orders that were say
orders note tips percentage of tips that
were paid either in cash or credit and
so it looks like almost 50% of tips were
paid in credit and 43 44 percent of cash
and then 6 percent of people did not tip
or the two rows including the two rows
that did not that gave a negative tip
that actually took money away okay let's
get to Python so I just wanted to look
over some stuff so I'm importing the
whole universe here
and get our CSV and printing out ahead
and here is our first scatterplot there
I have a mouse don't know what amazing
so here's the scatterplot of tip amount
on order amount you can see lots of tips
on the $1 $2 $3 $4 $5 out you can see a
lot of tips on the even dollar amounts
and some some outliers for sure I think
there's a 25 dollar tip that I'm not
including in here and then like
100-something dollar order then I'm not
including but yeah that's a pretty
simple scatter plot there's some more
cool visualizations on here's the cooler
one also scatter but it's also like
shaded so you see where more the density
is and then histograms on this on the
margins so that's uh that's cool again
you can see the even dollar amounts
there as peeks it's kind of looks almost
normal
I mean not not right here but both sides
look almost normal and there's almost a
suggestion that people would tip
negative if it were socially acceptable
like it cuts off at zero but here's a
much cooler scatterplot so you see that
most quarters were around the $3 and
then 18 dollars for a three dollar tip
$18 order amount and let's create a
histogram
so here's a histogram of all deliveries
this is what I was talking about so if
this uh
it almost seems to suggest it would
continue over here and people would be
like now keep some of my money if we
were socially acceptable yeah here's a
histogram of oops
oh no I press f5 instead of f9 so it's
running the whole thing right now no
stop
spoilers avert your eyes I could press
control-c okay hmm
f9 here's the histogram of Sam's
deliveries I think I'm gonna zoom
through these because they start to get
a little bit repetitive its histogram of
mine a lot more centered around 3 & 4
dollars there or 2 & 3 I should say and
and then here's uh both histograms you
can compare the distribution I think the
the bin size is not the same though so I
I collected a bit more data than Sam did
there and I have a rinse did not print
output okay
so right here I was print oh okay great
so that's it for the dataset overview
now it is time for some statistics I
there were statistics and there were
weak correlations everywhere I not sure
I needed to go back to slides
so the first statistical test that I did
was a difference of means t-test and
that was to see if there was a
difference between my average tip and
Sam's average two people always want to
know who gets tip better and so you know
to tell difference it means t-test was a
good way to see if there was a
difference at all
and so here querying the data and then I
don't think so first I collect the
ingredients right for the formula or the
statistical test and first it was the
counts then the means and these are I
hand coded it because I didn't know any
better I didn't know very much I still
don't know very much but I it was good
to hand code aid like look through the
textbook and be like okay I need the
accounts I need the means and ADA
standard deviations variances row by
line by line of code get them standard
deviations and then degrees of freedom
finally and so then putting it together
I I don't know if you're familiar with
the difference means t-test but you have
this numerator and the denominator and
so for the numerator it's it's pretty
simple just the Meuse which is average
pretty average I'm getting none so
average is the difference of averages at
the top and then at the bottom you have
the square root and then some some more
math using those same ingredients and so
we get a t statistic from that which is
negative zero
it's very tiny negative point zero or a
zero point three one no I can't zoom it
and so yeah that is a really
quote-unquote bad T statistic so if we
have a a hypothesis test here
technically I should have done in the
beginning but we're just printing out
the null hypothesis that our that our
tips are equal and alternative
hypothesis that our tips are different
and our significance level is 0.05 just
because that's how it is I guess and
here we get our p-value with the T
statistic our p-value is it's very small
here zero point three seven seven four
nine so it definitely definitely fail to
reject the null hypothesis our
statistically we can maybe assume that
our tips are the same even though we saw
four cent difference in the beginning
with just the averages and so why does
this matter
first we're gonna do another statistical
tests let's see so if I run a linear
regression just get that parameters from
tip on distance so this is a the next
statistical test to see if people tip
better or worse as you got further from
the store I recorded distance to the
point one mile from using Google Maps
and the this is our parameter so we have
a intercept at three dollars and two
cents or three dollars three cents and a
distance a coefficient of fifteen or
almost sixteen cents so presumably you
get it you know at zero zero miles you
get three dollars three cents tip and
then as you get further and further out
you get a 16 cent increase per mile
and let's take a look at this model so
this R squared always makes you laugh
[Music]
0.01 so basically no none of the
variance in the data is explained by the
model or almost none and I knew this
data well and I knew I need this this
batch right here like I know you guys or
gals and I knew that that those
deliveries were probably from a
neighborhood that was tucked away in the
foothills and so if we look at some more
summary here technically the the model
is statistically significant as a
p-value of zero but it's so bad and that
it doesn't matter and see and not oh I
have to do a forgot one
there we go so if we look at just the
yeah so I know these deliveries here and
I know that they are or I suspect at
least that they are skewing my model so
if I look at the average tip overall and
then the average tip for those
deliveries that are far away which are
greater than five miles we see an
average tip of 339 which we already came
across before and then an average tip
for far deliveries which is 509 so
definitely being skewed somehow so if I
filter those out and I'm filtering them
out because they're from 33 out of 38 of
those deliveries are from a neighborhood
called Hidden Springs and in Springs as
well - do they tip better they tip an
average of five dollars and that's quite
high and so there's that's a confounding
variable on my model my amazing model
with an r-squared of 0.01 is being
messed up by these hidden spring tippers
so if I remove those I get an awesome
our skirts it's like our skirt limbo how
low can you go right zero point zero
zero zero so that is to say it doesn't
matter how far away you deliver you're
gonna get tip the same pretty much this
is a statistically insignificant result
awesome and okay here so all that to get
insights from no insights people are
going to tip where they're going to tip
virtually everything was out of the
drivers control yeah so for the first
statistical test which is difference it
means T test so I want to focus on
this idea that when I had a bad night it
wasn't or I learned that maybe it wasn't
a reflection of me but rather it was
just bad luck people were going to tip
what they're gonna tip and so this
information is worth its weight in gold
when I am delivering past midnight and I
am waking up at 7:00 for classes and I'm
taking you know I'm overloading myself
and so getting bad tips having a bad
night can really weigh down on you and
really burn you out which affects
performance I mean if you want to talk
it from a heartless business standpoint
it affects affected my performance you
know and then maybe I get worse tips
because I'm not as cheery going up to
the door
yeah what's you record the amount of
time it took from an order coming in
until the customer received it I
strongly highlight it if it's like 20
minutes yeah yeah it's gonna be less I I
did not because they the problem with
that is because you go with for multiple
deliveries sometimes so if you have
three tips you might leave the store at
a certain time but what if you you know
deliver two and then and then then I'd
have to collect that a we I we tried to
keep it as simple as I had a partner
delivering pizzas to try to keep it as
simple as simple as possible so I didn't
collect data on that but that would have
been good at least for the single
deliveries to to record on that
and the second one despite having an R
squared of 0 there is an implicit
variable I hadn't discussed and that's
time so if a driver wanted to maximize
their tips they should just go for
deliveries which are close to the store
because they're gonna get the same
average tip no matter how far away they
are and so if they're going closest
store gas isn't as big of a deal as a
lot of people that I've talked to about
this seem to think time is a much much
bigger deal if you can go for 10
deliveries as opposed to 7 that means
more money at the end of the day gas
isn't as much and then also if a driver
didn't want to optimize for tips but
rather wanted to optimize for a relaxing
night then go for that Hidden Springs
faraway ride get to get a big tip roll
down the window put on the sunglasses
you're good and
so I would say no results are harder to
communicate but totally worth it
and they're worth it really because of
this quote by Dizzy Gillespie who was a
jazz trumpeter and I was a Jazz Studies
major and so of course I'm going to
quote jazz musician and he says it's
taken me all my life to learn what not
to play and so this really cuts to it
and I think a lot of businesses and
people focus on what to do how do we
increase tips what's the one solution or
maybe what what are the solutions what
should we do what our to-do list and not
so much on what's our not to do list
what is the waste of time
and what should we not focus on even
just emotionally focus on like me
focusing on a bad night and no results I
argue that no results provide hints of
where we shouldn't allocate resources
and this is a bit harder because imagine
data analysts or data data scientists
being approached by their project
project manager or product manager and
the data scientists so I have good news
the millions of dollars we spend on this
project we're a total waste and we can
stop wasting this money and we can
increase our process profitability
because there's nothing there there's no
change and I just don't see that
happening very much or I don't know it's
hard it's it's hard
and so I argue that no results can can
provide hints as to you know what should
we not focus on and so that's my Twitter
register to vote y'all and I feel like
strike right now like that was it thank
you so much that's it
[Applause]
any questions maybe you're like this guy
doesn't agree no questions
that's okay yes well what's your what's
your view on tipping now that you
realized tipping is not really tied to
your performance so what's my be on
tipping now that it's not ice I would
still uh
hustle up to the door if I were to go
tonight to deliver pizzas I would still
do a little jog you know put on a little
show for the for the person wait like
waiting for the pizza and smile just
because I think it's it's good - might
as well you know it's a very very low
low cost thing and if it increases your
tip great if it doesn't do anything you
know sure so I think yeah I would still
try oh but you didn't ask that
yes what's my view on tips I don't know
[Laughter]
any other questions it's okay no no
questions okay three the final call for
questions okay so if anybody has
questions you can ask me later I know
okay thank you very much
[Applause]